[Music]
humanity has defined itself using sound
and music
but what is the real power of sound
and can music be used as a tool to
control the minds of people
it's well established that all things
resonate but would you go as far as
saying that feelings are a form of
vibration
it's about what other people are doing
it's not about the science
you can use music to change actions and
behaviors of human beings do you think
that's actually part of a hidden
political agenda
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anything that your brain produced these
are all various types of vibration
this particular tuning was just harsh
enough that made it good for crowd
control the bottom line about the tuning
thing is how do we relate to other
people
if music is a tool that we use to heal
and to feel better
can it also be used to cause harm
i have a deep connection with music
for me music is divine
a form of energy that affects us even if
we aren't aware of it
an energy that i felt the first time i
touched the musical instrument
a very special energy
[Music]
i am convinced music has the power to
heal
soothe and bring joy as well as do the
opposite
[Music]
i have always liked numbers in
mathematics
and music is mathematics
rhythm
chords
and tuning
all have to do with numbers
and numbers in music
have to do with vibration
vibration is everywhere
in sound
image
movement
even in ourselves
our very own heartbeat is a vibration
this could be why music has a special
effect on us
there is a theory about shared resonance
which links between our consciousness
and vibration
tamhan the scientist and specialist in
the philosophy of mind is behind this
theory
he also wrote the book eco-ego eros
i want to ask you about a paper that you
wrote and about the relationship between
consciousness and vibration
in today's you know conventional physics
it's well established that all things
resonate at some frequency and that
means everything is vibrating there's
always some movement some vibrations
some resonance
when certain things come into proximity
to each other they start to in many
cases resonate at the same frequency
that allows for a combination of those
items into a larger resonant hole
when you have these tiny things
resonating together
their little bit of consciousness in
that piece of matter combines
then it goes up a hierarchical scale of
complexity
from the very simplest things to complex
things like humans
so the way i vibrate
can have an effect on or influence
people that are around me it does yeah
right now i mean there's various levels
of vibration you know you are speaking
to me
and your vocal cords are making a
vibration through the air
being picked up by your computer's audio
and being sent by my computer speakers
to my ear it resonates my
sensory apparatus in my ear which then
goes through various other test
resonance to my brain
and i experience your voice and the
meaning of your words in my mind it says
one level there are other levels of
resonance and what we're saying in our
general resonance theory of
consciousness is that everything is
simply a series of nested hierarchies of
shared resonance
when you have parts of the brain
that
resonate together
this is also called coherence when you
are conscious you have various parts of
the brain that connect through these
large-scale
shared coherences shared resonance when
you are sleeping
you have very high delta rhythms and the
various parts of the brain are kind of
doing their own thing
it's not chaos per se but it's
definitely far less coherent than when
you're conscious
so consciousness is related to resonance
would you go as far as saying
that ideas and feelings
are a form of vibration yeah for sure um
anything that your brain produces
whether it's a feeling of hunger or
irritation or happiness these are all
various types of vibrations of shared
resonance and we can then over time
develop a library
of waveforms associated with certain
ideas
with intentions with you know feelings
and then that is basically the external
representation
of those feelings
according to tam hunt
our feelings
our thoughts
are also a form of vibration
we vibrate like music
what would happen if the entire
vibration of music as a whole changes to
a different frequency
would we
notice this object is called the tuning
fork
[Music]
it was invented in the year 1711 it
vibrates at a particular frequency of
432 hertz
or 432 vibrations per second
the musical scale has seven notes each
one of them corresponds to a particular
vibration
and when you tune an instrument you
match the la note or a note above middle
c to the vibration of the tuning fork
then you tune the rest of the notes
using this as your reference
in the 20th century it was recommended
by an international conference that the
a above middle c note should be tuned to
a standard of 440 hertz or 440
vibrations per second
before the standardization many people
tuned their instruments to the frequency
of 432 hertz
and some people claim that tuning your
instrument to this frequency produces a
sound that feels more
natural and that the standardization to
440 hertz
was not an innocent decision
alan cross
is a music composer and radio
broadcaster he could explain more about
this
can you tell me about the theory that
says that tuning your la note or a note
to 432 hertz is actually more natural
and has a relationship with sacred
geometry
we have to go all the way back to
pythagoras
who came up with a
divine series of ratios between tones
and if you follow pythagorean theory
about how music should sound
you end up with a slightly different set
of pitches on our scale
than we're actually using today
the question is
what should middle a sound like and if
you talk to pythagorean people they'll
say that it should be at 432 hertz it
does make a slight difference
to the ear compared to a song tuned to
440hz
they don't sound artificial
they sound more
natural
do you think that standardizing to 440
hertz
is actually part of a hidden political
agenda
everybody has a theory
as to where
this 440 hertz middle a standardization
came from
there are people who believe that it was
the nazis and goebbels who thought that
this particular
tuning was just harsh enough that made
it good for propaganda and made it good
for mind control and made it good for
crowd control
there are other people who will insist
that no no no when the standardization
came in uh about 70 years ago the
rockefellers were somehow involved and
they wanted to make sure that
music conformed to their will
now there's no proof of that but it's a
great story
do you think we can actually use music
to influence people to change their
behavior
you can use music
to change
actions and behaviors of human beings
all you have to do is go to a meditation
ceremony with some tibetan singing goals
and see how that makes you feel
all you have to do is go to a dance club
and wait for somebody to put on that
great song with a drop in the middle
that makes everybody go wild you know
there's a reason we have national
anthems there's a reason we have martial
music for people going into war
there are reasons why we have protest
songs and religious songs so all this
stuff is used to
affect the attitude and emotion of the
people who hear it
so if we go back to our 432 440 hertz
conspiracy you can see why some people
believe that if there was a cabal an
illuminati type group that could change
the way
music was presented to the planet
well then this may have some interesting
crowd control propaganda
mind control
aspects whether it's true or not whether
somebody actually
thought this through all the way and
actually
implemented it so that it works
that's another story
don't you think that in the middle of
all these loosely connected ideas and
information
it is possible that you may get lost
this is exactly why i ask questions
to be able to discriminate between
reality and randomly and loosely
connected ideas
but sometimes reality is just some
randomly and loosely connected ideas
[Music]
music is part of every single culture
that i know
it is used to celebrate or cheer us up
or to mourn and quiet our souls
music is vibration
and music is mathematics
[Music]
four plus three plus two
equals nine
and this to some people
is a divine number
[Music]
the composer giuseppe verdi was a big
supporter of the 432 tuning
that's why this tuning system is also
called verdi's la
it is thought to be a pure tone
mathematically consistent with the
patterns of the universe
it vibrates with phi
also known as the golden ratio
a ratio found in geometrical shapes of
nature
and even in our dna
some say this pitch can be connected to
everything
from nautilus shells
to the works of ancient civilizations
some people argue that 432 hertz
resonates with eight hertz the schumann
resonance the fundamental
electromagnetic beat of the earth
maybe that's why it feels better
i found a website of an american
musician johnmichaelswift.com
who has an interesting view we've heard
all about the conspiracy of the 440
herds
can you as a musician tell me your point
of view about it
in my experience there's two kind of
main ways of thinking
on this issue there's sort of the
scientific camp over here and then sort
of the spiritual camp over here
and you know the scientific camp tends
to really want things that they can
measure things they can verify has to
kind of fall within the realm of
falsifiability potential want to see
evidence approve it's wrong or is right
and what i've tended to find is that
while the spiritual camp for me really
hasn't shown me what i need to see
to believe in 432
the the scientific camp also has to come
to me and say well this is how we would
prove that 432 is a non-resonant
frequency or has no has no special
properties so there's no way to prove
this theory either way
the bottom line about the tuning thing
is how do we relate to other people
you know
a432 is a pitch standard a440 is a pitch
standard it's about what other people
are doing
it's not about the science
and when you choose that pitch standard
you're choosing who you align with
you go with a440 you're going with
western classical music you are going
with western scientism that is your
choice if you choose a432 you are
choosing
spirituality um and really maybe to a
certain degree to align with other
certain traditional groups although when
you choose a pitch standard you're
choosing a group
and and you're going to get a lot more
than just the music with that you get
the people too and everything that goes
along with those people
everything is vibration
the whole universe is music
[Music]
in fact
scientists discovered that even black
holes vibrate at a very deep b-flat
pitch
57 octaves lower than middle c
and our voice vibrates too
i also think truth is a vibration
a special kind of pitch
for me searching for the truth is like
tuning an instrument
i'll keep listening to the truth
and i'll keep asking questions
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you